well the migrant crisis is about to get
even worse if you can believe it since
October there have already been over
730,000 migrant encounters at the border
right now a caravan of at least 6,000
people are trudging towards the US the
illegal immigrants are demanding help
from the Biden Administration uh making
the harrowing trick over Christmas
weekend the president of the United
States must help us as we are migrants
in reality some of us only go to the US
for four five six seven years and then
return to our country for this reason we
demand that Joe Biden help
us I was used to my Christmas dinner
with the family not spending it in the
street as we did
yesterday first Christmas that we spent
away from home and not in the best way
as we expected to give the best to our
children all right well make demands I
guess Sanctuary cities are also fing the
pressure almost 4,000 migrants in Denver
are overwhelming shelters with more bus
loads arriving in the city here in the
next few day in the last few days
Colorado governor Jared polus well he
was blasted for not taking this issue
seriously instead he posted this video
of himself dancing and
laughing
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jessica nobody loves Jose felicio more
than I do even when I say his name
wrong I I love the song he sold more
albums than Mariah carry I saw him live
with our very own Raymond Ayo last week
but is that how you uh address this
crisis that's happening right in front
of us I don't think that that is his
migrant crisis approach I think that
people are allowed and yes was a little
cringy but they're allowed to post
something on social media that has
nothing to do with the real problems the
city is facing I understand if it's
something that is affecting you
personally that might be aggravating to
see but Jared polus is a complete
success story he has a 61% approval
rating he's in the top 10 of Governors
across the country and he's actually
more libertarian than he is democratic
I'd encourage everyone he was on with
Bill Maher and had a wonderful interview
um with him about it last year
so I think there's a place for this do I
wish it had been better coordinated and
less and look less awkward 100% but I
don't think that it means that he's not
serious about the Border crisis and he's
spoken out about it saying you can't not
give us federal dollars if you want us
to deal with thousands of people that
are being shipped here like Democratic
Mayors and governors are doing all over
the country so I'm
propolis I I I don't know I got a lot of
my neighbors are from Denver and they
couldn't get out of there quick enough a
couple years years ago uh so I don't
know maybe he doing a better job doctor
if we just want to go by the numbers
because you know numbers better than any
of us okay there as many as 10,000
migrants arrested per day at the
Southwest border in the last week till
on top of that there are 10,000 a day
seeking Asylum just coming in through
Eagle Pass it's hard to put our finger
on the total number because the guideway
number is a prediction or or a
guesstimation but the numbers are unlike
anything we've ever seen before our eon
isn't doing all that well right now is
this not I mean it's almost malpractice
on behalf of the administration if they
want to take care of these people well
so first of all we don't know the number
of the Goda ways but the number we do
know is the 2022 2023 fiscal years over
2 million migrants did cross the
Southwest borderer that's not even
counting the people who have come in
from our northern border a quarter
million just came in last month alone
and as we're talking about Denver they
just had 16 busloads of migrants being
dropped off on their doorstep I do think
that the video I think it was really bad
timing it was very cringeworthy that
gets added to you know Jill Biden's Taco
comments you know President Biden saying
well you ain't black if you aren't for
me I mean they are just so thirsty for
this black brown vote and they you're
starting to see all of a sudden you are
having more support for president Trump
the polls are showing when it comes to
Hispanic Latino and black voters and the
reason is because of how they're
handling the border and because of their
economic policies people are hurting at
home I I agree with you I come from a
town that's 78% Hispanic right now in
inside the city limits I I was talking
about this morning on Fox and Friends I
I kind of had this epipal moment sitting
there it's like you know what is it
they're my people the people that came
to Dalton Georgia from mainly Mexico in
the 90s and 2000s are a part of my
family they're the people I went to
school with for 13 14 years they're
they're best friends they're first
generation Americans some are dreamers
and they say to me my parents and
grandparents weren't what this is they
weren't coming here this way they
weren't coming here from even those
countries and they weren't coming here
to do what those people were doing which
was to complain about not getting enough
from America and so Tom when we look at
these Caravans and we look at the
situation coming through Mexico not from
Mexico is the Camala Harris approach of
you know go find the root of the problem
that I guess this problem has no roots
is that the only thing we can do yeah
and you're talking about your people if
you talk to uh Hispanics talk to people
bluecollar workers up in Westchester who
are out there doing landscaping guys who
are working as contractors they've been
here for years and years they don't like
what's going on they see the flood
that's happening and they worked hard to
get the jobs that they have and now they
see these migrants coming in so they
have the same attitude about it as
America's uh blue collar workers do um
and I think these cities the sanctuary
cities I am sick of this act like that
mayor Adams is putting on and these
other guys mayor Adams saying oh they
got to do something we're getting
flooded here and then the headline is oh
mayor Adams is really mad about the
Democrats policies and he know he wants
something done he just wants money all
right they are Sanctuary cities they
invited these people here now they want
to petition the government for money and
this is part of a a two-part scam I say
this all the time the idea if you have a
street scam you have one guy running the
scam and then you have somebody else
who's kind of a phantom operator and
they pretend to be taken in by the scam
and they work together that's mayor
Adams he's the silent partner in this
he's going to demand money and then once
they put up the money once Biden gives
him the federal money they're going to
federalize the migrant situation and so
that the cities now have a new source of
income the federal government is giving
them money for every migrant that comes
and they're going to have more migrants
coming here candy a lot times Democrats
roll their eyes at this what they call
the replacement theory that they want to
bring in people of of their politics to
eventually have the vote the right to
vote or their kids have the right to
vote to change elections they they roll
their eyes and say that's conspiracy
theory they call it racist so what is
the what is the mindset of keeping the
Border wide open how does that make our
country better what what is the truth
behind there there is an idea that you
should let people into the country
especially seasonally to fill jobs that
Americans just won't you know and and
people who want to work as hard as
people you see in your hometown that
have been there for decades they're some
of the hardest working people in this
country so if we had a better
immigration system you could welcome
those people in and if they felt
comfortable then they would leave and
and go back and provide for their
families seasonally or for a couple
years at a time that's not what is
happening we have such a confusing
immigration problem and lack of policy
in this country it is almost impossible
to immigrate here legally so but what is
also interesting is it is kind of racist
because Republicans go well we don't
really want to talk to these people
because they're invading our country and
Democrats go they're great because
they're going to vote for us but there
are Hispanic voters that are peeling off
from this President because a lot of
them are from Catholic countries and a
lot of them are much more aligned with
traditional Republicans who are are
trying to outline and create a better
Coalition in their party so they've been
essentially ignored by everybody and
while KLA Harris says that she's working
on those root causes the problem is
absolutely metastasized on her watch so
whatever the root causes were two years
ago this whole new thing whatever
they're doing it is not working and
shame on them because it hurts people in
these border towns it hurts people in
these Sanctuary cities it hurts homeless
veterans who can't get the care that
they need because resources from the
federal government are going to people
like the first guy we saw on the video
who is demanding something I'm sorry but
there is an aspect of it that I I really
have an issue with and it has gotten
worse under this Administration listen
if you have respect for hard work taking
care of your family and and the society
around you I really don't care what
language you speak what color your skin
is or where you're from I want you
around I really do cuz there's a lot of
Americans that don't have that anymore
uh but we need to make a way to get them
here legally hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else